hello there reject nation I'm Greg alpha
tell them your name my dear I am Julia
Tran failure
Julia failure is my leader my director
really quick we're gonna watch movie
scenes an but Julia is a director of a
short film called Civil Defence Red
Rover which I act in it's an alt history
war short they got big plans for the
future guys I have been in some other
short films before but I want to bring
Giuliana today because this was one hell
of an experience many many many months
in the making the short film came out
great we did a screening at a theater
for arena cinta lounge I think I did ok
I'm barely in it everything else is
awesome I said I think I did ok I think
you did fantastic that's a director
talking right there seriously go check
it out I don't want to ruin anything for
you it's really well done and I'm so
proud of everything great it goes
through some hell yes my 5 seconds of
screen time out of 10 minutes you are
the heart and soul sir I'm selling the
sizzle you are this is not to stake all
right all right all right there gotta go
see it to check out more I can't even
obviously use your eyeballs we are
moving on you like Jackie Chan I do I
love Jackie Chan he was he was one of
the main reasons I got into film really
which which movie was it I was like four
years old and Rumble and the bronx came
out and then I thought more about the
incomparable Jackie Chan has been
thrilling audiences for over four
decades of a singular combination of
insane martial arts skills that's great
I'm gonna probably have seen all the
movies
[Music]
yes sir dangerous cheating death
virtually every time you makes a movie
here are a few scenes that posed a grave
danger to their life
himself action stars it's actually a
little scary sometimes master snake in
the first one first rocket mass 1378
introducing his distinct comic touch and
distinguishing him from the great Bruce
Lane the movie also featured rising star
Huang Shang Lane the king of the leg
fighters whose powerful kick king of the
leg fighters chemistry was so good Oh
apparently failed to learn his lesson he
suffered one of his first major onset
engines kick tanks connected with his
brow bone breaking it and nearly causing
him to lose an eye 2014 interview
hawaiian jang lee was asked to rank his
top 5 kung fu fighters and he didn't
hesitate to rank jackie chan at number 1
thanks oh you love this you love like
Chaplin and stuff mom Buster Keaton if
you love this group the turn of the 20th
century and it's pure slapstick comedy
by way of blinding martial arts and
insane stunts were one of the most
dangerous things shall never did appears
in the finished movie and it may have
been the first scene to give audiences
the notion that China may be superhuman
in the scene Chen's character angles in
the face whatever
the dump he actually did it that yeah
actually about it after losing his grip
and falling six stories through a couple
of mornings Sandman's directly on his
head Janet injured his spine during the
stunt but the camera doesn't cut away
instead extras dragged him to his feet
and he continues the scene starting with
the 1985 originates is probably my
favorite Jackie chairman said the
shopping mall Jan jumps from a railing
on to a pole or covered in Christmas
lights the glass was fake SH an at least
it wasn't sliced to ribbons but the
lights had heated up the pole causing
him to sustained serious burns on his
hands the hard landing also dislocated
Chan's pelvis and injured two vertebrae
rough the stunt looked great in the
finished film house there's no way they
were getting a second take close just a
brush with mortality while shooting the
1986 film armour of God in Yugoslavia
Chan had to jump from the wall of a
castle to a nearby tree branch a
maneuver that I'd normally be able to
pull off in his sleep instead he came
crashing down onto the rocks below
cracking his skull and sending a piece
of it into his brain resulting in
doctors having to put a metal plate in
his head it seems like the kind of thing
that might was an action star out of
commission for good but the near fatal
injury simply became the highlight of
armor of gods outtake reel and over the
next two decades channel would continue
to risk it all for the enjoyment of his
millions of fans armor of God to
operation series released in 1991 sees
Chan in Indiana Jones mode chasing after
hidden treasure and dealing with secret
cults and hidden Nazi bases it's packed
to the brim with crazy fight sequences
and stunts but it was another reasonably
simple task that nearly took channels
told me once only twice man
clever editing Heights Chan's a terrible
tumble during filming in the extended
scene China actually loses a scrape on
the chain and plummets to the ground
even though you know about this one he
gives a thumbs up it could have been
worse particularly he might have finish
the job he started on project day and
dislocated his head Police Story three
Super Cub it's safe to say that most
leading men have never had their face be
rearranged by a helicopter an incredibly
perilous sequence in 1992 s Police Story
three super cop has chan leap onto my
rope ladder dangling from a chopper more
the pilot attempts to shake him off that
wasn't even the dangerous part when the
helicopter later lands on a moving car
look at him Chan has to do is avoid it
as he dangles now rotating away
apparatus
a myths revealed in the outtakes
resulted in a frame broken shoulder and
a dislocated cheekbone there we go
sixteen years the drunken master to
receive a sequel 1994 there was direct
drunken master its climactic fight
sequences legendary but it was almost a
very different son disagreed with the
director's vision for the final scene
and the conflict led to him quitting the
uncompleted production Chen himself took
over directing duties and decided to
repeatedly whisk lighting himself on a
fire yeah he actually like invented a
new style
what makes how it's even more amazing is
that the take in the finished film it's
a second one
Chantal thought the first take it didn't
have the proper weather so me shot it
again might even play my places Chan in
the middle of international intrigue
working with a CIA agent to solve a
mystery surrounding missing scientists
while dodging hitmen in scenic locales
and of course performing one of the most
insane stunts ever puts a film Rotterdam
in the Netherlands is home to villains
where one of the world's more unique
skyscrapers it features a sloping glass
facade that runs down one entire side of
the 24 story building in the climactic
scene of the film John slides down the
entire length of the facade
[Music]
Shyne accomplished the stunts by
literally just sliding down the entire
length of the Posada unassisted with no
harnesses on jarring halt catching
himself from flying over the edge it
took in two weeks to work up the courage
to attempt what might be the most
dangerous stunt what's a filmer new
police story I have not seen this one
brief series obviously wanted him dead
could have been forgiven if it wanted to
skip the 2004 reboot new police story
coding characteristic fashion he threw
himself into the film's kinetic action
scenes with gusto in one particularly
terrifying scene Chyna pursues a gang
member who distracts him from the chase
by going down the driver of a loaded
double-decker bus channel deeps onto the
roof of the out-of-control bus which
proceeds to cause massive property
damage while the hazards come at em fast
and furious
it's easy to sequence it wouldn't really
be a Jackie Chan movie I don't want to
know what his insurance on these films
were like well that's that's the issue
with while he's when he does in American
movies is the insurance like they won't
let him do it for I remember for rush
hour one great movie oh yeah classic
should have won Best Picture yeah for
rush hour one he had some simple summary
ran up a tree and and then I forget the
position onset they're like whoa what
are you doing he can do that he's gonna
get he's gonna get hurt like it's Jackie
chin like no you got put wires on him
like something he was not want to use
wires yeah there's a lot were in
American films where they wired enough
where normally he wouldn't used wires
sometimes had to use a double just
because of insurance policy purposes and
stuff yeah I'm surprised Tom Cruise is
able to get away with as much as he gets
away with now that's why he also
produces his own movies Tom Cruise so he
could do those stunts I think he would
like some of his older films because he
does have a you often have a job Charlie
Chaplin you have a cat that looks like
Charlie yeah yeah he's got a nice little
stash even though everyone thinks Hitler
but you call him Chaplin again I think
it's a little more paging yeah I think
you really like project a for that
purpose police story has got to be my
favorite one but he's about to go down
the pole he he he was saying how he had
to let up this yell because he had to
work up the nerve to do it I think with
performers like Jackie Chan you'd think
that they can just handle stuff we took
two weeks to get ready for that slide
down a building and I'm amazed that he
didn't psych himself out at the end you
know to me I know I can't even like look
over the edge of some buildings would
you scatter or a bunch of joke I like if
some be recorded there's a lot more
things that you
get'em disguise i ever bungee jump if
there if there is a video of it there's
something about well you know people not
want to see you know there's a camera
I'm more likely to do there's a lot of
things I went to if there's a camera
recording as opposed to without a camera
recording I don't know what that says
about me you're daring I guess you gotta
add that way if there's an audience
there that's level of narcissism applied
to it but I don't get actors like this
you know who are just willing to do this
but he comes from a different time he
grew up in Peking Wu opera it was the
first biography I've ever read was his
book I am Jackie Chan the amount of
scrutiny and discipline and training
that he had to go through growing up
sometimes from reading that book like
well what he does in the movies is kind
of a walk in the park compared to the
insane level of discipline and torture
and Punishment the literal punishment
that they would inflict on their
performers to be the best they can be
Jackie Chan was conditioned to be this
human being who would do all these crazy
things you know and I mean I guess it's
just so wonderful that he's at least
able to share with people and like he's
inspired so many people to get into not
only filmmaking but martial arts and
study performing from various aspects
and stunt coordination is so integral to
these films and the fact that he's his
own stunt coordinator probably why he
gets away with doing some crazy stuff
imagine the hours behind all the
rehearsals he had to do and all the
camera rehearsals like it must have been
pretty dangerous for the camera crew
behind it too you see that that one shot
where he jumps from the truck to the
side and around the billboard and the
camera just veers right under and it's
right here yeah and I imagine that you
know camera distances you probably
needed a good at least six if not 15
feet between the lens and the billboard
but it's so close they quite literally
have to swing it up and hide them
there's a billboard well he comes back
in well we would call like guerrilla
filmmaking style in the States a lot of
its Kimi common practice in Hong Kong
that movie Who am I where he goes down
the skyscraper
[Music]
there's a simple stunt well not a simple
one but there is a stump where they had
an American it was like is partially
funded by an American company or
something and there was a stunt there
they were taking six hours to set up and
Jackie Chan got like annoyed and then so
he's just like nobody I do this my way
to hurry this up and then literally in
30 minutes they set it up they needed
this car to be on its side and start
spinning and what like that they were
building this contraption that was
taking all day and so he's like no we're
just gonna get my stunt men just run
because this is taking way too long
their safety precautions are not as
intense as ours out here so that's why
he does a lot of Hong Kong films and he
said like well the money is in America
thinks the filmmaking process takes way
too long in the States as opposed to out
there where you can get these kind of
crazy shots you don't have to worry
about all those insurance wiggle room I
mean that suppose makes his career so
special is how he puts his life on the
line somewhere she's got a whole a
permanent hole in his skull I mean I
wonder how many injuries total he's had
in his life and those medical bills and
they compounded it's one of those things
that it's not like oh he got a head
injury
now he'll yeah that's not how any of
them work and it must really impact how
he can pull off any of these stunts
because you know if he's got a bum foot
you know like he can really land and do
a flip properly he has to kind of
compensate for that but his recovery and
I want to know how he does it there's
some magic there on our short film I do
my own stunts
yeah you did I I jumped over something
really slight and ran and grabbed
something you ran over a pile of
sandbags over a ditch so it was probably
a good 4 to 5 foot drop six weeks of
training well we had Dylan Wilson our
amazing stunt coordinator who is on set
keeping things safe we did up stunt
rehearsals for the knife fights and all
the other crazy action but you were
running your name they were alive he's a
pro we don't need to train him we just
got to see you run man actually for
Dylan to me it was simple it was like
all right I just got to get up and jump
over this bag some big deal
you look me up and down and went how
athletic are you God what do you think
my physique first for something so
simple
yeah well you couldn't hurt yourself
reason to believe so I really into it
anyway guys go check out that short film
civil defense Rob you'll see him run you
can check out that physique that Dylan
was looking at yeah you should go check
out my male modeling Instagram page to
handle subscribe to looper subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
about to get notified oh never got a
video up I like to end this with a
patron the day shout-out JT JT is our
Japanese man from Hawaii now JT look
this is gonna sound racist but I assure
you it's not if you have to say it's
racist say it's racist it's probably
racist Greg I was gonna say JT I am
shouting you out because you are Asian
and Jackie Chan is Asian so it only
makes sense to shout out the only Asian
patron eject that we have you need a
little more diversity here I think I
mean Jackie Chan's Chinese and you're
Japanese but in some circles they would
consider it the same racist circles
racist sister that's a that's a
reference that not a lot of people will
get it's from star kid but that's okay
you have made this shout out so much
better everyone else won't get it your
contribution I'm sorry JT I've tried
I've shot so many times and uh you know
me I'm gonna resort to something racist
or sexist is also my initials
you should have gone there first you get
it behind the scenes shout out of let's
try to figure out how to show you out
today JT good man thank you staging